hey everyone it's Mike from order flows
there and welcome back to my channel you
know in today's video I sort of want to
follow up on a couple of topics I've
been talking about uh recently you know
stacked imbalances uh they're effective
on the market how to spot them
um and as well as lack of uh volume in
the two-way auction you know these
pockets of illiquidity so to speak that
carry importance basically because you
know it's a sign of a market moving
quickly and today I'm going to be taking
a look at the ZN the 10-year notes on
the Chicago Board of Trade
and it's the reason why I'm talking
about uh tenure no States because it's
it's a contract that trades a lot of
size
um you know if you look at the depth of
Market you can see there's thousands on
the bid thousands on the offer up and
down the order book and you know when
it's trading bid an offer it trades uh
very good size right on the footprint
chart you'll notice
um this is a four range chart you know
it trades thousands
um basically at every price level and
today was it was quite an active trading
day and I like to use a four range chart
on treasuries as opposed to a minute
based chart
just because if you're on a one minute
chart
um there's it's a little bit difficult
to analyze the order flow because price
is often trading just uh the bid and the
offer sometimes for you know a couple
minutes straight and really what you
want to be using the order for is seeing
how the market is moving how it's
reacting to the order flow and if the
market is just flatlining it's not going
to give you much to go off of at least
with a range face chart you know bars
are formed as a result of a market
moving
okay so uh first thing I want to talk
about is
stacked imbalances right and you know on
normal markets like e-minis
um you know most of us will look for
stacked imbalances of three or more so
for example
um you know if I were to pull up the
settings here I'd go under stacked and
balance and you know have the minimum
cluster size set to three click apply
click OK and you know I'm going to be
specifically looking for these
imbalances of uh three or more either
buying imbalances or selling the
balances stack neatly on top of each
other let's see if we've got any like
here right nice stack selling and
balance okay there's another stacks on
imbalance
you know another stack selling imbalance
and oftentimes you know the market is
going to come back and test those levels
all right but on a market like
treasuries right the Dynamics are
different because
it's not as a wild moving Market as some
of these stock indices like NASDAQ or or
mini Dao and to a certain extent uh
e-minis so
you'll get movement but you know
especially if you're looking at a full
range chart and this would apply if
you're looking at a four range chart on
say wheat or beans or you know any of
the Agricultural markets or even like
crude oil and I still know some people I
used to look at a four range chart on
e-minis
um I think that moves too fast but on uh
treasuries right any any bar that you're
looking at on a four range chart is
going to have five price levels and so
to get three imbalances stacked neatly
on top of each other you're talking most
of the bar to be out of balance in the
sense that you know three out of the
five price ranges are going to be either
buying imbalances or selling and
balances stack neatly on top of each
other so what you'd want to do ideally
is you're going to go into stacked
setting for stacked imbalances you're
going to change it to two right so
you're going to be looking for levels
um you know stacks of two on top of each
other as opposed to three because again
you know if you're looking at three on a
four range chart you're not going to get
much right here was today there was a
nice buying and balance you know the low
of the day is this red line you got a
nice buying and balance here again going
into the low you got to stack sound a
balance of three Mike just said well
it's rare to get three
yeah generally it is I mean you look
here let's see there's another two here
there's another two here
um there was two here right on the close
right before the close
um you know two here as you're going up
two here as you're going up this was
right on the open
um there's two here
right there's a two here
there's three here going into the close
three three but again this was right at
7 30. you could see you know when the
number came out people say well you got
a nice move here but honestly just all
this movement happened right uh when the
number came out the other day this was 7
30 double O seconds to 7 30 and 56
seconds so within a minute right we had
this big move so you know again I don't
Advocate trading during a data release
um nevertheless we had a stack selling a
balance of two levels right here this is
about uh 30 minutes before the number
came out
um
stacked buying a balance of two here
this Market went up
um here's two here here's two here
here's two here and you know it's just
uh it's just something you got to adjust
right because people sometimes you know
they think a stack buying a balance has
to be three or more well yeah it should
be in general three or more but if
you're on a shorter range chart meaning
you know the bars aren't going to be as
big as normal
it's not going to be effective you you
know you're going to get just a handful
of stacked selling of balances on a full
range chart
if you're using three okay that's why I
say use two okay and you can see and you
know for me I'm a big believer with
stacked imbalances especially take them
in context of the market right if you're
at near the high of the day right and
you're seeing silent balances here here
here here coming in I'm gonna put more
weight into these as opposed to the
Stacked buying and balances coming in
right off the high right now that
doesn't mean that the market can't go
higher but you know anytime we're up
near the high of the day I'm always
looking for a legitimate reason to get
short and you know there's no stronger
legitimate reason than the market being
out of balance and you've seen Stacks
selling and balances coming in near the
high you know if a market made a low
starts rallying up you know I see a
buying imbalance
that's even better for buying imbalances
again we're coming into the lows here
yeah I mean we this this was the result
of a number right here but you know I'm
always hesitant to really
looking to get short going into the low
of the day
again you know the market can make lower
lows right here right this was today
stack selling a balance going into the
low and then you made a new low by one
two ticks then you bounced in reversed
back up so again take them in context of
the market now
we actually have another feature on uh
orophos Trader and I'll probably make a
separate video on this uh
in the future but
uh let me just turn off stacked
imbalances
and it's called multiple imbalances
right because you want to know where you
know bars that have
more than one imbalance in them it
doesn't mean that just because they're
not stacked on top of each other
you know it's not important okay and
with the order flows Trader you know one
of the tools that we put in there is the
setting volume and balance to
specifically highlight those bars
either green or this is actually like
what it said tomato or something like
that are around the actual candle
just you know it's just a visual thing
to tell you hey you know what you got
multiple imbalances coming in here so I
just know we just made a new low here
right it's a double bottom you start
pulling away I've got two bind
imbalances on here right they're not
stacked on top of each other
but does that mean they're not important
no they're still important
you're just spread out in the bar
okay and it's actually leading into the
second thing I'm going to talk about is
the volume inside the bar here's two
more stacked imbalances right you sort
of pull back right in here
from this swing High you got two buying
imbalances coming in here okay just as
um
you know here's two solid balances off
this hide where the market do just went
down a little bit then went sideways but
you know up here at the high of the day
okay again like I was saying in context
of the market here you've got
two bind imbalances going into the high
okay another two going into the high
okay I mean when you're going into the
high You're Expecting there to be
aggressive trading right taking the
market higher what I'm really looking
for is any sign of weakness and the sign
of weakness is going to be those selling
imbalances one two right now they're not
stacked neatly on top of each other but
they're still two selling imbalances in
there there's five price levels in this
bar two of which are selling imbalances
to me that's important and you can
actually
I don't use it but um you know I use a
lot of zones like drawing zones on my
charts but I don't use it for multiple
imbalances
um mainly because when
um I I used to you know on the previous
versions of ninjatrader and Order flows
Trader
um we just used to put a box around it
but you could actually draw out a Zone
from it'll draw it out here let me show
you it's easier to explain
um oops
where am I here
okay
well
it's gonna it won't draw it out actually
it'll draw it out from you know it'll
highlight the bottom price level of the
bar on a red candle here here and the
top price level of a bar
if it's an up candle so if it's a red
down candle it'll highlight the the
bottom price level if it's a green up
candle it'll highlight the Upper price
level you know we got a lot of zones
abilities to draw out zones on order
flows Trader and you know sometimes we
just really want a visual representation
um rather than drawing it out you know
in this case we just arbitrary we're
going to draw it out from one of these
imbalances or the bottom price level or
even you know the price below it I just
found you know if I'm looking for a
bullish signal and I see the green up
here at the top as well as the Box
around I know that I got multiple
imbalances I I the way I think of it is
was more of a magnet pulling price down
or pulling price up okay but that's just
something to give you a a visual okay in
case you know some of us we like to have
those visuals we'll also draw this
little triangle down for bearish ones a
little triangle up for bullish ones
okay so just really quick I just wanted
to touch on uh sort of follow up what
I've been talking about the last couple
of days about
um
lack of volume in the two-way auction
and you know the other day I was talking
about you know e-minis with thin prints
in the bar okay now with with e-minis
you know you could use volumes of like
five or even you know seven or eight
internally in the bar let me just turn
this uh multiple and balance off real
quick
and
get back to my chart
and while it's important right
um you know you can get with those
levels right e-minis okay so you know if
I was going to draw out
let me just show you here if I just
wanted to show the price levels in the
bar and turn off some of these things
not to confuse you guys
it it is turn off the stack of balance
I'm gonna go to thin prints right and
you know for this case I'll just use one
okay so volumes of one in the candle
right internally in the bar okay so
e-minis you know is a market that does a
good job generally of Distributing
volume throughout the bar okay so you
can see here as this Market is selling
off here's the zero it's a zero here's
the one there's zero here on the way
back up a one right a one Etc so you get
the idea right that's what I was talking
about but on a market like uh 10 years
right that trades a lot of volume
again you're gonna internally in the bar
there will be instances where you can
literally get a volume of zero or one in
the bar but you know you're talking you
know some of these bars you know they're
Trading you know look at this bar trades
13 000 on the bid 13 000 on the offer
six thousand eight thousand seven
thousand seven thousand Etc so you know
you can give it a little bit more leeway
and you know if you're going to use thin
prints on a market like
um
tenure notes treasuries you know you can
use a actually a bigger number and I
sort of alluded to that before I don't
know you could use 20 25 I'll just throw
20 on here
right and you can see right on this move
up 13 here four here
okay
nothing else on the way down today you
know I said today was uh quite active
and you know again in the middle of the
night you know one o'clock
take it with a grain of salt it's just
less volume uh you really want to be
focusing on it uh during the main
session so you know this you know eight
o'clock in the morning here
you know 7 30 was the data but eight
o'clock look at this you actually have a
zero coming in here at 756. it's very
rare in the treasuries if you can see a
zero you know that's got to get your
ears pricked up and you know thinking
you know let me uh pile into this
but down here at the low 23 16. one
okay it's at the low of the day you
trade one contract at 109.13
on the way back up okay Market makes
this move pulls back
all right you got this little bit of a
pullback
between zero here and the market shoots
back up right
it comes off pulls back
there's a rallies pulls back 12 okay
goes down a little bit and you know
continues back up so you know you see
the 17 here on the move back up coming
down
uh here's a 20. again you know you still
got a couple hours left in the session
and it comes off from this 20 contracts
you know keep selling off the rest of
the day so
again you know use Market context right
understand the market that you're
trading if you're trading a market that
um trades
you know much more volume than say the
e-minis or some of these other markets
that you trade you can adjust it up
right you don't have to stay at nine you
don't have to stay at five or one or
zero right if you're at zero you'd only
have
that one here
um you had some zeros during the number
but you're not going to trade that
during the number you know here's look
on the way up 25 where'd the market pull
back down to I'm sorry this is 23.
um pulled right back down to the level
and it traded close to 10 000 contracts
here
but then went back up and then on the
way back down you know within about a
tick of that original level then it
trades 25.
and then the rug gets pulled out and it
just just spends the rest of the
afternoon selling off so again you know
take it all in context of the market and
understand the market that you're
trading right every Market offers
opportunities
um but you just gotta understand sort of
the order flow for each market now does
that mean you got to spend six months
chained to your screen watching it trade
tick by tick no but you know you should
look at some charts you know get some
screen time in ideally
um
but basically you know understand how
the market moves and and the chart that
you're looking at and for me I've been
looking at treasuries on a four range
chart for over well over a decade decade
and a half
so it's it's easy for me to talk about
it but again you know if you're coming
into a newer Market
um you know just find out how it moves
right I could look at something like
what is this Hogs he right and I could
determine okay what's good volume what's
weak volume you know just really quick
you know there's some interesting things
in in the hog market you know just was
um today right we had this nice double
bottom heavy volume on the low all the
same principles apply whether you're
looking at treasuries e-minis crude oil
Hogs even right and so the the same
Concepts apply it's just the volumes are
different okay so anyway guys have a
great uh rest of the day hope you
enjoyed this video be sure to hit the
Subscribe button and I'll see you guys
on the next video bye bye